hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so for those who are
watching my video for the first time i'm
a professional trader
and i'm doing youtube videos where i use
technical analysis to show you guys how
i build my different scenarios and how i
set up my trades so in this video i want
to make a long-term analysis on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so what is the situation
here so this is gamestop
let's let's do something a bit longer
term let's try
to take a step back and see what is
happening
where the price action might be heading
what kind of signals technical analysis
is giving us
do we have something clean and try to
get to use some
for example option interest data some
short interest data and see if this all
makes sense
and what the price action might be doing
so
let me sum up the situation here like i
did with amc basically i'm doing
those two a lot because this is what you
guys want to see this is the first
reason
so i'm trying to give you what you guys
are looking for
and the second reason is that they are
actually moving together all right they
are
both like some iconic stocks from reddit
wall street bets and you can see that
the flows
are actually coming usually together
into this
stocks sometimes we see the flows coming
out from gamestop
and coming in amc sometimes the other
way around but when we have some strong
bullish moves it's usually correlated
that's why the analysis i'm gonna make i
quite similar but they have some
differences as well for example on
amc we just had the one two and on game
stop
the correction here was actually shorter
and the one two occurred before
in my idiot wave counting so those are
minor differences
but still it's not exactly the same
thing but
on the longer term it looks actually
very similar we had this strong move up
here
which was a short squeeze for gamestop
not a short squeeze for me for amc
then we corrected abc so this is one two
two three four five
all right once again my target long term
target
is 800 all right i'm not sure when
we're gonna reach this level but i'm
confident we would
okay something like this everything is
very clean here one two three four five
abc here we're having a one
two all right so this is the difference
between amc and gamestop
a gamestop is actually more bullish here
the correction was shorter on gamestop
and
we're having here this one too with the
abc correction and we're starting one
two three four five
we are seeing the volume slightly
picking up you see here on those bullish
days when we actually break
the 160 level that i told you guys was
very important to watch we broke it
we are having a nice bullish development
and the question is what are our targets
when is the next correction gonna happen
so i'm gonna try to give you here some
hints about
what we can expect so to do that i'm
always gonna use the same methods
i'm gonna use horizontal and sloping
trend lines
where i had consolidation in the past
and some nice reactions in the past to
actually
bring me to the most likely levels we
could go
to and here when i do this exercise
the first thing so this is the price
action we're having now
the recent press action is giving me a
highest level at 216
so i put this trend line all right this
was a rejection level
it's going to act as resistance then you
can check if in the past it was acting
as support or resistance you can see
that
it was here it was actually a support
level in the strong move down we had
then got broke down with a strong gap up
down sorry here as well it was
supporting the price on the daily time
frame quite well
and rejecting it as well so this 216
17 level is an important level that
we're gonna see
acting as support or resistance in the
future
first is going to be resistance then it
might be support for example here
right so this is a level that you can
already have in mind
guys i'm giving you this level quite
early because for now we are only at 178
once again guys i may have some delay
i'm sorry about that i don't have time
to do
daily updates so i'm doing a few videos
in the same day i'm just publishing it
you know on a daily basis so sometimes i
have some delay and i'm sorry about that
so when i'm doing my video gamestop is
trending just closed at 178
and i'm expecting the price action to
keep go
higher so i hope i'm gonna be right here
but if i'm wrong i'm still gonna publish
this video
because i think that whatever happens
here we might still
see 216 trading soon i can even tell you
when this is the beauty about technical
analysis 216
is the level i got using horizontal
trend lines i'll show you guys how i did
it
then i'm gonna connect the high that i
have here
so the all-time high 480 with the second
high we had
in this correction which was 340
and when i connect those two highs this
is giving me this trend line guys right
and this trend line is going to act as
resistance as well
very interesting is to notice that those
two intersect
on the force of may so this is giving me
time targets and a price target this is
giving me some very precise information
this is telling me that gamestop might
be trading and be rejected on the 4th
of may at 215 so once again this is very
precise information
the probability i'm right here is not
that high
because it's a very precise scenario so
maybe we would go there the next day
maybe the day before
but i noticed that when i do this kind
of
reasoning with intersection between
different trend lines
it gives me some level and if it fits
with
the rest of my analysis which is for
example here the third wave of idiot
that would then need to correct
somewhere so maybe it's going to go here
and then you know
maybe we're going to break it right away
and retest it you know it can be as well
like this
there are different possible scenarios
but this is telling me that there's
going to be a lot of selling power at
215
and of course as this is just in this
wave development we're gonna see
a lot of by the deepers coming probably
i'm not sure 170 190 level you know all
this area
so for now we need to be focused on what
is happening around the 3rd of may are
we actually getting close to this level
or not
one of the information i like to use
guys and you know that it's the option
open interest i'm an option trader guys
and you can check my previous video
i had here 21 which was
around maybe 12 million shares i don't
remember you can go and check
but this is the total synthetic short in
shares equivalent so this is not the
synthetic shop we're having right now
because you need to use a delta that is
here that i compute myself guys you know
i showed you guys this many times i use
this
barbaric formula but that is actually
quite simple
the open interest 100 times the delta
and times the level of game stop and
this is giving me the synthetic
short so for now we're having around
seven percent of the total float
share that is 55 million of short
interest
and if gamestop goes to 10 000 whatever
we converge to 32 and before what is
interesting guys is to
see the difference because this is
showing you what is the
sentiment and the difference between
this week and last week
is huge guys it's ten percent of total
open interest so once again it's not
delta one so it's not ten percent of
short interest it's maybe one or two
percent of short interest
but on the upside it would eventually be
ten percent
more if gamestop goes above all these
strike levels
and let me also show you guys that
the levels are just insane the maximum
number of shares
is 2.5 million and we found it at the
800 strike level
once again i get all this information
from yahoo finance which is public
information
so go guys and check it out by yourself
you're going to see that this
information
is correct and this is very bullish sign
guys you know once again for a firm like
apple we usually have 0.6
of total synthetic short interest for
amc we're having six percent
right now but not at the 11 level we're
having five percent and for gamestop
we're having seven percent with a
maximum at 32 percent
so guys this is what can create a gamma
squeeze this
is very bullish and one more information
i like to look at guys is the volatility
of this 800 strike and i told you guys
that
it was 193 last week so now it's 191
so it's slightly lower so this is not
bullish
but two percent over 190 percent is very
minor so as long as we are both once
you know 70 180 it's fine if we go below
it means market maker are not scared of
this 800 strike and they're just selling
call options without protection
this high volatility means protection
for them means they're scared
means it's bullish so this is how i
relate
what i find on the option market like i
check the volatility i check
the strikes i check the open interest i
check the total synthetic shot
and i check the maximum synthetic short
and when i check all this information
they're all telling me the same thing
is that people are very bullish and
when people are bullish usually
institutional clients are following the
retail investors
so it's actually telling me that this
scenario that is very bullish guys very
bullish
is still on the table and is still my
preferred scenario for now
i'm gonna show you in another video why
800 but i'm just using few extensions
for now
it's too early to discuss this let's
first go to the 215 level
let's get rejected retested and then
break it out on the upside
and then we're gonna see what is
happening so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you can be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys